so please don't worry about the central
attacks this thing will be visible later
so
i will start with using whiteboard for a
while just to demonstrate that
mathematicians also can
use whiteboards not only in computer
presentations
so
actually it was suggested to me by erhan
and that perhaps it's better if i show
you some examples of other semi groups
than only semi group on the cube just to
give you some comparison right because
perhaps it will be more clear
what happens on the cube if you see some
classical semi groups related to physics
for example or some other
situations
i just will clearly more clearly see
some analogies to what happens on the
cube so let's start with something very
trivial
we start with our space being the real
line with lubbock measure
the velocity will measure space
and now once we have a function f
we make pt of f
in the following way
that we just set pt of f at point e x to
be equal f x plus t so we just use a
uniform shift we move in a uniform way
in one direction and we just move the
graph of our function more or less right
this is this is the classical shift so
it's easier to check that this is
actually a semi group in the sense that
p0 is identity and pt plus s is equal pt
composed with ps
fact this is a quite rare case of the
semi group that can be also defined for
negative times and
have good qualities when you move both
directions that's quite exceptional
behavior you know with most semi groups
inversion of time
you you cannot really go
it's a group right
so this is a very untypical property of
this of this seminar usually you cannot
expect such things but here we have even
the same nice behavior for negative
times no problem here
and well what is the generator now
l f
of x so by definition
this is minus d over dt
f of x at t equal to zero so of course
when you differentiate it you will see
that this is just minus f prime of x so
in other
words we can say that
the generator of this group
is simply
minus
derivation operator of course there is a
question on which functions you can
actually do the differentiation and for
example we can restrict to
continuously differentiable functions or
smooth functions or
whatever is your preferables based on
which
derivative would work nicely so
just to demonstrate
what are the potential problems when you
try to recover the semi group from the
operator
let me recall that
on the cube there was no problem with
writing this as a
infinite series
right on the cube there was no problem
everything was bounded and nicely
converted so if we try to do that here
then we would get that ptf
at point x
should be and when you implement this
and you re recall
that
the case power
of the
differentiation is just taking the case
derivative what we'll end up with
will be just the following formula
right
which is not very surprising because
this is just a taylor's formula
uh
in fact it will be plus because l is
minus derivative so these two minuses
will cancel out
okay so we recovered the taylor's
formula
uh
and what was my cover at my coverage was
that even if the function lies
in the domain of the operator it doesn't
have to
lie in the domain of operator squared
and so on
but this example shows that even if your
function
lies in the domain of all
powers of operator l you still can get
in trouble
even if this formula makes sense you
still can get in trouble think about
function
f of x given by the formula
exponent minus 1 over square
of x for x
different from 0 and 0 otherwise
this is well known that this is a smooth
function you can differentiate it
over the whole real line
it's c infinity function
and obviously this function
has also the property that
k derivative at zero is equal to zero
this is quite easy exercise
this first
year of mathematics uh exercise usually
and you can do it on scratch
so
this shows
and actually when you try to apply the
tailors from you know you easily see
that
you get in trouble right
so this is an example of a smooth
function that doesn't uh well it has a
taylor
series and it's a convergence just
because our coefficients are zero but
it's not equal to its taylor series in
other words it's not analytic right and
of course this is nothing very special
to this function most smooth functions
are not analytic and
this is how
things are simply so this is an example
warning that
even for such a simple semi group
recovering the summing group from
operator may be a
difficult
or at least tricky
tricky thing
so
there is yet another thing about this
semi group that
one should be warned about so i told you
before
that
one of the basic things that we would
like to have
is that when you apply the semi group to
the constant function equal to one you
would like to recover one so of course
this is satisfied by this semi group if
you shift the constant function equal to
one you get an again this function
but if you remember correctly i told you
that usually we would like the functions
on which we work to be integrable with
respect to our measure
and in fact we use it uh
in our notation right so here of course
the situation is completely different
because this is not a probability space
rebecca measure is infinite
function one is not integrable and so on
so in many practical situations
when people use semi groups in
analytical context there is a problem
for example constant function may not
lie in the appropriate class of
functions
and well as you can see here on real
line just with usual algebraic structure
the hard measure is infinite just
because this is non-compact
non-compact space it's only
it's only locally compact right so
this is just to
to show you that even in such simple
examples
there are some things that somehow
run out of the
uh of
the setting that we discussed we
discussed mostly things that happened on
probability spaces
uh and
in the case of the discrete cube we
really didn't have fortunately to deal
with all those technicalities but they
will show up in almost every other
okay so if you want to get rid of the
trouble of
living in non-compact space having
unbounded measure
a infinite measure you can easily reduce
this example and take everything modulo
one
then you will live on a circle instead
of of the real line you only restrict to
one periodic functions and you get the
same semi group
more or less the same operator i just
derivative will be
on circle with respect to rotations
right and then everything becomes
compact the back measure restricted to
the circle
may be made probabilistic after proper
normalization and then
things become better from some points of
view but still
one can get in trouble when talking
about the domain of the generator and
recovering the summing group from
generator right
and this
this really
is a bit more delicate
okay so now i would like to concentrate
on two
important examples coming from the world
of physics and actually
these examples are also important for
historical reasons
because this is actually where the
harmonic analysis came from
so all the fourier
series uh ideas fourier transform and so
on have their roots exactly in the two
semi groups
that i will discuss now so first of all
there is something that is called
brownian motion
and
i guess that most of you heard about
varian motion i will not give a
strict definition of what it is
but i i will just for those of you who
may not be very experienced with
stochastic process i will just try to
give a
vague intuition what brownian motion is
like so we start
we'll discuss things on the
real line only
so we start at point zero
and we
consider a discrete time
we will take some very small times steps
and then we will go with delta t to zero
and uh and somehow brilliant motion will
be what happens in the limit when delta
t goes to zero right i will try to
describe the finite
approximation of bravian motion so what
we do we are at some point and then with
probability one half we move to the
right
by a distance of square root of t
or we move to the left with probability
one half
by a distance of square root of delta t
this square root normalization the the
scaling is
actually the appropriate one other
powers wouldn't work that nice okay and
then
we just do the random work right we got
to some point and in the next
stage
for the next delta t time we move with
probability one half to the right by a
distance of square root of delta t and
so on and so on so this is a symmetric
random work on the real line
the spatial steps are square root of
delta t the temporary steps the temporal
steps are delta t and then we pass with
delta t to zero and what we get is some
way of
movement over the real line okay and
then we can prove theorem that such
limit exists
that the trajectories of the
of a point
uh with probability one will be
continuous that's with probability one
it will be
nowhere differentiable and so on and so
on such object is called brownian motion
this is not not a very trivial
mathematical object it took some time to
mathematicians to
to establish the basic properties and to
to find a good
definition but anyway
once you
once you get this sort of
thing you may look at this brownian
motion as a markov process and we
discussed the connection between markov
processes
and between
semi-groups right we know that every
markov process defines a semi group and
conversely every semi group
under some technical assumptions
defines a markov process so we have this
brownian motion process xt i would call
it actually bt
this is the standard way to to denote it
sometimes also wt
winner processes
is used
okay so we have this
vermilion notion and then of course
we recall
that
the way
we
recover the serving group from the
process is that we take expectation f
and now we should take this process
starting from x
and going for time t
okay
but
this is the same
as just expectation of f x plus b t
right because if we start from a point
different from zero uh
the whole image the whole picture is
just shifted
by x right
this is space homogeneous
okay and now
once you know this process once you
see that this is just a limit of
of such plus minus one symmetrical
numbers it's very easy to prove
that the distribution of
bt
at at fixed time t is nothing else as
the gaussian random variable with
variance
okay so this expectation is nothing else
an expectation x plus square root of t
times g where g is the standard gaussian
random variable n01
this is just the consequence of the
construction of bravian motion as such
limit of radenbacher plus minus sums
and using central limit here
nothing nothing complicated here
okay so this is our summing group
this is called heat semigroup
unreal line
and now you can ask about generator of
this semi group
so
we need to compute
the derivative
so i will assume that function f is nice
enough that it's smooth and it decays uh
fast enough so that we can get with
integr with differentiation under the
under the function
yeah i would like to do that but i just
don't know how to and
and how much time it would take to
recover
this is the question can we switch the
screen thing off for a while and then
bring it back
it will not take much time thank you
very much
okay so now we just differentiate this
thing
so we get the derivative of of square
root of t which is one over two square
of t
expectation
f prime x plus square degree
okay
and
of course g will come out
when we do this derivation right this is
under the assumption that everything can
be done regularly right so
there's some assumptions about function
f must be done that this is smooth
enough and
and
the tail of derivative decays nicely but
this is a technical part
okay so now
what we have here
we can just explicitly write down what
this expectation means we integrate over
real line f prime x plus square root t
y
exponent minus y squared
y d y
we just use the knowledge about the
density of the standard gaussian are not
variable
but now
we may notice
that we have
a term that is a derivative of a
function
in natural way
so this is just d over d y
exponent minus y square 2 with minus
okay
y
exponent minus y square over 2 can be
written as such derivative so now we can
integrate by parts we can shift this
derivative
to the first term and then the minus
will cancel out
again under assumption that when we go
to negative infinity then plus infinity
the term will disappear right we again
listen something about function f but it
behaves nicely
and we end up
at
1 over 2 square root of t
1 over square root 2 pi
minus cancels out
when we differentiate this thing
the square root of 2 will come out
because we
take derivative with respect to y
here we have second derivative of x
and here
so
actually
we end up
square root of t will cancel out one
half remains and what remains is the
gaussian density so we have here just
expectation
second derivative x plus square root t
g
but obviously we are interested in the
case when t goes to zero
we are just interested in the right hand
uh derivative at zero to to compute our
uh
our
generator
and when t goes to zero
this goes to zero
if you assume that function f has
continuous second derivative
again under some assumption about their
decay you see that distance to
one half
second derivative
which means that the generator in this
case can be reasonably thought of
as minus one half laplacian
okay we discussed the thing on one
dimensional line so this laplacian is
just the second derivative in higher
dimensional situation
you just consider brownian motion in the
n dimension so that you run an
independent previous motion
each coordinates separate the end
and
then the generator obtained from such
macro process would be minus one half of
the laplacian so when you put things
together
this means
that
the
derivative over time
ptf
of x is equal to minus one half
pt
f
of x and here we have laplacian with
respect to the spatial
coordinates okay so when t is equal to
zero this is exactly what we computed
but if t is not equal to 0 if we don't
pass with t2 0 we end up here
and you just see that this thing is
nothing else
than
the semi group applied to the second
derivative of f
okay
this expression is nothing else
this thing is just the semi group
applied
to the second derivative of f
right
so
you can read things this way okay so
if you consider the function
g t x
as p t f at point x function of the
coordinates this means that d d t
g
is minus
one half laplacian over exegg and this
is the famous hit equation
that's
exactly where the whole theory started
at
so physicists were interested
in understanding
how temperature
would
disperse on
on the real line or on the plane right
and the thing that
in fact
fourier started with was
the example of a metal rod metal bar
that was uniform you have some initial
distribution of temperature over it
and he was considering the case when
both ends of the bar were put to a
thermostat say water with ice and cooled
to the temperature zero and then the
question was how quickly
the temperature of the whole bar will
decay to zero right because that's
obviously what physicists expect that's
right that
that the whole
whole bar will cool down to zero if you
keep
the ends
in the coolers right water with ice but
the question was
how actually that would look like what
time it would need what would be the
shape of temperature after some time and
so on
and
quite quickly they got to the
understanding that this is the equation
that describes the thing that
if the second derivative with respect to
spatial coordinates is negative
if temperature has a peak at some point
then in this place it should very
quickly go down
and if it has a
low place at some point then it should
quite quickly
get warmed up by neighbors right
and of course
that was some more systematic treatment
about that so what are the morale of
so i will not somehow refer to what
fourier was actually considering because
this
case is a slightly different thing you
have some binary conditions and you end
up with trigonometric functions
in our situation it's slightly different
on real line if you start with some
distribution of temperature that is
compactly supported for example if you
have some
smooth necessarily measurable function
and it's compactly supported
you know what will happen on real line
the temperature will slowly go down and
disappearing in infinite
right that's that's quite natural thing
to expect this is completely different
from
things that happen for example on the
discus cube that we'll
think about in a moment
because the cube is compact and the
temperature doesn't have any way to
escape right on complex space
temperature cannot escape to infinity on
real and this situation is different so
if you start with a comparatively simple
function it will
slowly or fast depending on the shape
decay and and go to infinite
uh
so
what is the morale the morale is that
you can quite reasonably think about the
temperature of
uh
in such situation as a collection of
many little particles that was at the
time of logistance here yet right so
imagine that at the place where the
temperature is high
you have number of small particles of
heat that is proportional to the
temperature right and in the places
where the temperature is low assume that
it's always not negative right you can
always do such a
shift of the scale of temperature to
make it negative
so you put small number of particles
a large number of small particles
just so that the number reflects the
temperature the density of particles
reflect the temperature and then you
allow each particle separately
independently from other to move
according to a brownian motion
and then what happens after some time
when you average because of the low of
large number
pt of f the image after time t will be
the average history of those particles
right
so actually the fact that from starting
from bound motion
and using this avalanche over
trajectories that you come back to the
heat equation
means more or less that you can treat
the movement of heat
as move
movement of independent particles each
of which is moving independently
according to a brownian motion right
this is a quite interesting
phenomenon that you can describe things
this way of course
actually the hit in real physical world
doesn't behave that nicely right
in the sense that we know that this is
not about flogging or some other
separate
physical quality but it's rather about
kinetic energy of thermal movements
spreading from
in the crystalline net for example right
but
the description is very similar right
and at some level of accuracy this is a
very good
a very good description of what happens
when the temperature is moving so
because this is called heat semi group
and because this has this very nice
physical interpretation
this semi group that we defined on the
cube is also called the heat seminar
this is called the heat semicolon the
discrete cube because it's as close as
it gets i told you that there is no
variant motion on the descript cube just
because the marine motion has
trijactories
that are continuous on the descriptive
by its very nature it's not possible
but the
markov process that we described the
continuous time
random walk on the cube that we
constructed it's as close as it gets to
the bravian motion it's
time homogeneous and it's space
homogeneous it looks the same in all
vertices of the cube
when you take the isometry of the cube
and
you use it to
to change coordinates
you will not see the difference in the
behavior of the process
and it's time homogeneous right the
transition matrix doesn't doesn't depend
on time okay so this is as close as
things can get to the bearing motion
on the disc
cube right so this is called hit
semi-group and actually you can you can
view it in a very similar way right you
have temperatures at two in power and
vertices of the cube and they undergo a
similar
thing only you don't have nice laplacian
instead of a laplacian of this form
differential which is not available you
need to use laplacian of this form
right
you look at the differences between
temperature at point x and its neighbors
meaning the vertices in hamming distance
one this is as good as it gets you you
cannot do better on the disc
okay and now another important example
that is
also coming from physics
to much
extent this is einstein wollenbeck
process
so now
uh again i will first
i will again do this on real line
and i will again describe some intuition
how this thing works
so you start from some point not
necessarily zero
again we have some time step delta t
and what we do we are at point a
at time t
at time t we are at point a
we move
first to the point exponent minus delta
t times a
so first thing that we do
is we dilate everything collapsing the
whole real line
towards zero
okay
of course the scale of this collapse is
very small it's uh it's close to one
because the delta t our step of time is
is a small number but uh we make this
dilation collapsing things
to the zero
and the further we are from the origin
the larger the collapse will be of
course because this is a linear
direction and after that after that
first step
you
add the noisy thing which is with
probability one half you go to the left
by square root of delta t and with
probability one half you go to the right
by this step square root of delta t
so
actually here you can
you can make the direction by a
parameter kappa times delta t and if
kappa is equal to zero
what we get is just the brownian motion
right this is a limit case of the old
england back when kappa goes to zero and
well you can do this for different
scalings i will just take couple equal
to one just to to avoid too many
constants here okay
and then you repeat the procedure so you
dilate by a factor of exponent minus
delta t then you make a random move to
the right or to the left then you
collapse again
make a random step and so on and so on
and so on and then again you pass to the
limit with delta t you go with delta t
to zero and what you end up with is a
new thing
which is a gaussian process called
onstage rule and back process
so
now it behaves differently even though
it's still on real line just because of
this collapse
collapse part in our move
things will not escape to infinity and
actually whatever distribution you start
with whatever point you start with
it goes in distribution
when t goes to infinity to
the standard gaussian random variable
right whatever point you start from
after a long time your position will be
approximately normal
okay and so of course this means that
the standard gaussian measure is
invariant under the semi group
okay so now again
what is the semi group ptf
at point x where this is expectation
of f
of
this
process if we start from point little x
now
i will not give
the proof of that but again this is some
use of the central limit theorem more or
less
the exact formula for that will be
exponent minus t times x
plus square
root 1 minus
exponents minus 2t
g
where g
is the standard gaussian random variable
okay so you can see when t goes to
infinity this thing will stop to matter
much
and we will end up just with expectation
of f with respect to the gaussian
inversion right so whatever temperature
you start with again this may be viewed
as a hit semi group sort of
but now
the underlying measure
with respect to which one should view
the things is the gaussian measure
so
this is sort of i want to pass this
intuition to you this is sort of
compactifying the real line real line as
a topological object topological object
of course is non-complex
but by putting on it gaussian measure
which decays very quickly we sort of
compound they compactify it from the
point of view of what happens under the
original redback process okay
and this corresponds to some physical
uh
yeah
yeah and in fact the original black
process may be also written down just as
a time and space rescaling of the
brilliant motion i will not get into
details
but
well this is the whole theory of the
gaussian processor yeah but yeah that
definitely has
also physical applications and what is
the generator in this case
so i will not not make the computation
but
generator at point x
is x
scalar product with the gradient of f at
point x
minus laplacian
of f
x
this is so called
our training and back operator
uh so it can be computed directly
uh and again
you need function to be in some nice
enough class to to have this operator
the good thing is that
many technicalities are easier in this
case just because of this sort of
compactification and
and many things may be done very easily
and now
i just want to turn your attention to
the fact
that in many ways what happens on the
discrete cube is actually closer to the
original and back process than to the
brownian motion right so in the first
stage i told you that
our process
our time continuous
random work on the tube
is similar to gravion motion as close as
it gets
but actually
also one can view this thing as very
strongly related to the oversignal and
back process and what is the reason
imagine that you have some function on
real life
and you consider this real line with
gaussian density
so you can simulate this function
in the following way on the discrete
cube
you take the point x from negative 1 1
to the power n and you make a new
function g
on the cube
you make it from the function that runs
from real line into real line
in the following way that the g of x
is defined as f x 1
plus x n divided by square root of n
so this is a symmetric function on the
cube it depends only on the sum of
coordinates
so it's in a way a one-dimensional thing
but it lives on a descript cube
okay and now you can apply the
usual semi group on the cube
to this function
okay
and then you can see what happens when n
goes to infinity
and when you apply the
cube
the the the semi group hit semi group on
the cube to function g after moving
things to the cube and then you go back
to the real line
just to read what happened to your
function here on real line if you use
the central limit theorem do some
computation you will end up exactly
referring back process
okay so also
process is a limiting object of the
random work on the cube restricted to
the symmetric functions right and it's
quite clear that if you start with
symmetric function function whose value
depends only on some of the coordinates
then after running this cubic
hit summing group for a time you end up
again with a symmetric function right so
this is a good invariant familiar
functions okay
so in a way
uh
this
semi-group on the cube is much closer to
what happens in the on-screen run-back
setting than with what happens in the
gaussian
i guess if you have smooth enough nice
function probably you can also recover
recover things about generators right
because you have comparison between
summing groups but then you you must put
very strong conditions on knife
actually you can also under different
scaling and if you do the whole thing
not on the cube with uniform measure but
you take the product of biased measure
which i i
didn't talk about and i will not have
enough time to talk about but you can
leave the whole theory to work also for
the biased cube
you take just
negative one one with some two point
measure but not necessarily symmetric
and then you take the product
you can
after taking appropriate scaling you can
get as a limit the poisson
measure right on the integers and then
you can read the whole thing
uh as the standard queen
i don't remember
the formal name so the thing is you have
some number of
uh
of customers
and then with some intensity in the time
delta t you will get
a next customer
and those who are look at the present
each of them independently is served
with
some probability and disappear right
so whatever number of customers you
start with after some quite quick
process you will uh get to the poisson
distribution
this is uh the poissonian version of the
ornstein rule and back and in fact ocean
runway can be also viewed after properly
scaling as a limiting object from this
poissonian thing that happens okay so
all of this is interconnected actually
you
you may first get the poissonian thing
and then pass from it to orange and run
back
okay so this is just to show you the
connections between things of course
what happens in the cube is much richer
than what you get on the
ocean
situation but this is sort of of
convincing you that
there is no
very good and universal analogy between
what happens on the real line and on the
cube because from some point of points
of view
this semi group behaves like a brownian
motion
but from some other point of view we
have like a ocean run back
and neither of these parallels is
perfect i mean both have some advantages
and disadvantages and actually this is a
separate object that has its separate
properties and part of the problem is
that you don't have a real gradient and
you don't have a real chain rule when
you work with functions and you only you
have the discrete gradient and things
don't behave as nicely as in real life
okay so that was the end of the
of the physical and analytical
regression
which was just supposed to give you some
some parallels
i'm understanding what happens
can you switch the screen
okay thank you
uh so now
let's come back to the
so here are just uh
for record facts from the previous
lectures
just we need to use this formulas here
and there so now what is the poincare
inequality the this is another concept
that we'll be
uh using uh now
so the classical poincare inequality
comes from differential
equations differential inequalities so
when you have some region in rn
and what is important the region is
bounded and you have some function whose
support compact support is
strictly included in d so the
function disappears before reaching the
boundary of the
and you assume that this is uh
it has continuous
derivative continuous gradient
then we can easily get this sort of
inequality you just use some integration
by parts some kosher shorts will end up
with this inequality this is
what was invited
at least to match extent by pankara and
in fact similar inequalities were known
earlier in middle of
mid 19th century the physicists knew
some
some variants of this inequality and
triggers them in different situations
this concern depends on the on the size
of the region more or less and shape of
the region
it's not universal it depends on the set
d but doesn't depend on the particular
choice of function f
if only f is smooth enough so if you
think of it also as a function of d then
it's kind of like positive words where
like the two
like the two terms
on the right hand side are the cd and
the
cd is just a numeric constant
depending only on the on the
area d on which functions it's more like
respect
yeah this is a spectral gap inequality
of a sort
right the the thing is that you don't
assume that f has expectation has
integral equal to zero instead you
assume that it disappears when it gets
close to the boundary but
this is more or less equivalent up to
changing constant you can you can
rescale things
to move from one statement to another
okay so this is just to tell you what
where this thing comes from it comes
from
from this sort of
consideration but now we will consider
something slightly different so we
assume
that the function is integrable
uh we have some probability parallel
measure on rn and we will say that it
satisfies poincare inequality with
constant c
if
the variance of f with respect to the
measure mu
is bounded by this
constant c times
integrated square of gradient this is
called
the poincare inequality unreal on rn
and of course again you
need some assumption about the
smoothness of f just to to to give sense
to the right hand side okay and we will
say that the measure mu satisfies the
quantity inequality if for all functions
smooth enough this inequality holds with
this same constant c okay if we have
some uniform constant so this is
the inequality that tells you something
about the measure space about the
properties of measure mu rather than
properties of individual function f
which is sort of twist in in the point
of view because
the thing started rather from tendency
to say something about proper piece of
particular function
and now we want rather to say something
about the measure space
using f as a sort of test function
okay so another difference is that here
we have variance so we sort of
compensate for the expectation being
non-zero
right
we know that the variance of function is
the same as the variance of the function
uh shifted so that the expectation is
zero so this thing is shift invariant if
you shift f by constant it doesn't
change
so this is a slightly different setting
than in the original punk arena instead
of thing disappearing close to the
boundary
we get this sort of thing
the top equation you do or you don't
assume that
that the expectation of is zero on
on d i mean here we don't assume so in
the in the top because in the original
one you don't assume
that expectation is close to zero
instead you assume that the function
disappears when you get to the boundary
of the std
and then you do the integration by parts
okay okay so that's that's the
assumption
these are two different ways of
of controlling the function right one
you can say that it disappears in the
infinite or when you get close to the
boundary of some set and another
way of normalizing the function is to
say that expectation is equal to zero
and you can sort of replace one one for
another paying some price
but in our setting we'll restrict to
this i just stated this for historical
reasons and because in the community of
differential equations people would
rather use this normalization in many
situations right but but actually we
will rather keep
to this statement so we'll bound
variance instead of the second moment
but in exchange we don't have to care
about the tail behavior of the function
right
even if we are on an unbounded origin
error
okay
so now
on the discrete cube
we can replace rn by the discrete cube
and instead of this squared gradient
integrator we can take our uh
our discrete gradient let me let me just
remind you that our energy functional
looked like that so if f is equal to g
the energy of a function f
can be viewed as sum of the square
gradients right here we sum up over all
x and y's on the cube so that they are
immediate neighbors
but
having distance between x and y is equal
to one which means we sum over all
pairs of neighboring batteries vertices
okay so this is sort of integrated
gradient as much as as it is possible on
the description
okay so in our setting we will look for
something like that
we will prove that for on our discrete
cube we'll prove the concurrent
inequality with constant one
here
okay
and moreover we'll prove that if the
function on the cube is even
if it satisfies uh
the equation f negative x equal to f of
x
then
we can get the point inequality with
constant one half we can get a better
constant
one half if the function is here okay so
now both inequalities are quite trivial
let me show the proofs so we expand our
function f
into the walls fourier series we recall
that the second moment
is just the sum of squares of all
coefficients and we recall that the
expectation is the coefficient that is
that has the index empty set
so
therefore we can write down variance as
sum of all squares of coefficient except
the one that comes with the empty set
and on the other hand we have a very
convenient formula
for
for this
energy functional
over flf and we know that
it
appears in this form
we sum up the squares of the fourier
coefficients multiplied by s right just
because our operator l acts as a
multiplier and
multiplies the welsh
fourier coefficient standing
at s by a cardinality by the cardinality
of s right so we have explicit formula
for the energy function we
we
have seen
the proof of that equality yesterday uh
two days ago
okay
so now just because cardinality of the
empty set is zero we can drop the term
that is related to the empty set and we
end up here
so it's clear that this expression is
not less than this expression and we
have proved the poincare inequality with
constant one
and just because these are non-negative
terms and this is always greater equal
than one so the pointer inequality is a
trivial thing
okay it's just a one-line proof
now to prove the second assumption that
when we have an even function then
we are able to prove the pancreas
inequality with constant one half
instead of one
first let's note that when we have even
function then cardinality of all fourier
coefficient then all fourier
coefficients related to the sets with
other carolina
will be equal to zero we have seen this
in johannes stock several times and
and uh
i think it's quite obvious just because
this is even function this is odd
function so the product is odd function
expectation therefore will be zero
things will cancel out
okay
so now
uh let's see why our quantity inequality
of one half holds true by definition by
by our formula for
for the energy functional
this is given by this formula the empty
set doesn't really count because anyway
this factor disappears
so now
that's the same as summing over all
over all s with cardinality greater
equal than 2 because for all s that have
cardinality 1 the coefficients a s
disappear
right just because we assume that our
function is equal
so all
welsh fourier coefficients standing at
cardinality one will be equal to zero so
the term disappears also as well we can
sum over
s with cardinality greater equal than
two instead of summing over
different from the empty set okay but
now for cardinality of has greater equal
than 2 this term is greater equal than 1
and this is non-negative so we end up
here
now this again is summing over all as
different from the empty set for the
same reason as before
and this is just the variance okay
so you see that the proof is almost as
simple as the previous one
okay so this is called the spectral gap
in a quality
and the reason for that is that actually
what we have used we
restrict our operator l to the subspace
of functions
that are functions with expectation zero
and we look for the smallest uh
smallest eigen value related to such a
stated operator and this is exactly the
constant that we wrap you're in the bank
arena
okay this is a trivial
spectral inequality for those of you who
know a little bit about spectral
calculus
and actually
this is quite important also in physics
this sort of inequalities variance and
general qualities of spectral
inequalities because they are
responsible for the speed of convergence
to equilibrium so for example when you
have this
problem with temperature and you want to
estimate how fast the temperature will
go to zero when it spreads on the real
line
or when you do that on some some other
uh in some other situations then
this sort of inequality pancara in
quality will make it possible to prove
the exponential convergence and the
speed of this convergence will be
measured by the size of the spectral gap
this is a quite common physical
situation
but uh i don't go into the details just
to show you where it comes okay so next
thing that
i will need at some point it's an
elementary inner quality i i will not
spend time writing into the blackboard
and i will not spend time proving it the
proof is contained in slides this is
elementary i will skip it but just for
the record there is such an inequality
and it's trivial
i mean you sit down you use the fact
that it's homogeneous differentiate
several times a new point
the proof is contains in this slide
and now what we need this inequality for
is something that is called stroke
valoropoulos in the valley
so
still we restrict to the
to the discrete cube
and assume that you have a non-negative
function on the discrete cube which we
for measure l is our usual operator then
the following inequality holds and this
i will write down for the record
it's the stroke variables
this is very important inequality in
this year of semi groups
actually
the same inequality holds true for any
symmetric mark of semi group
which is not not as obvious as
on the discrete cube and the proof that
i give you
in the slides and i will not follow this
proof i will skip that part of
computation because it's technical but
actually the proof can be used
to deduce the thing on any symmetric
markov sending so if you are interested
into seeing how this thing works on the
on the arbiter the symmetric mark of
semi group you can read through the
slides and you will see that this is
nothing specific to the to the
description
but how to prove this inequality on the
discrete cube well very easily to
to
write down this expression and this
expression you simply use
this formula
that allows you to expand the energy
functional
the expectation of function l another
function
in the following form
of such a sum so you do that
so in this terms there will be f in
power p over 2
and here you will get again f in power p
over 2 over x's and y's that are
neighbors and on the right hand side you
will get f in power p minus 1
f in power p minus 1 and here we will
get f and f
and then you prove this inequality point
wise for any pair of x and y that are
neighbors separate and you just add up
these things
so what inequality you will need for
that exactly this inequality when you
write things down
the thing amounts to building this
inequality uh for each pair of x y
separately and then you deduce this two
parabolas
so i i will skip the proof of surge in
general setting but you can find it in
the slides if you are interested
this is just what we will need and this
holds for nap greater than one
and for f non-negative
uh yes for p equal to two it's identity
and somehow the case p equal to two is
sort of special
yes in a way it's tight
or although the way to see it is not
trivial so i told you that you can prove
the stroke variables on any symmetric uh
semi group so if you do that for an
original unboxing group and you recall
that the generator is given by this
formula when you plug it in
you will see that actually you have
equality in the stroke variables in a
quality
whenever f is say positive and smooth
enough
ah
that's a good question i think it's from
eighties and stu and veropolis proved it
independently but in the distance less
than the air so it's considered their
joint result in a way
and they use slightly different setting
and so on but
but that's basically
i think 80s i i don't remember
i cite it in some paper so i will check
and tell you tomorrow perhaps
that's not difficult to find out just to
understand on the cube the the external
cases there are symmetric functions
well if you want to get close to
inequality on the q
you want this inequality to get close to
equality just because you can emulate
uh the orange standard back thing on the
cube by taking symmetric functions you
can get as close as you want to the
equality case just by taking symmetric
functions
for the sugar pulse
for the super plus if you plug it in you
will see that you have equality for all
it's an identity yeah
yeah but there is some sort of tricking
because well
you need function f to be positive but
on the other hand
you want gradient not to disappear and
for many functions changing sign
when you want to apply these things
there will be some treating so
but for a huge class of function there
will be exactly equality so we are only
interested in having strong various
equality you can get it for nap
as close to equality as you as you want
but for some practical uses
you will get in trouble just because
the gradient thing
at some single point may
go to infinite or the laplacian
in some practical uses it's not as good
as what i wrote here
but if you keep the string positive
function and smooth enough you will just
get equality in the superpowers
this is just one line of computation
well
it's not that strange because
when you
see
how you use this elementary inequality
when the function is smooth enough and
you do this only over neighbors uh you
you will see that this inequality that
you use is close to equality and when
you add up the errors will adapt to
something
tending to zero this is not as strange
as it may seem in the first moment
okay so
in a way this is a tight inequality
what i find strange is that
somehow in the queue
what is quality of almost equality it
just drifts into one way and becomes
popular yes yes and actually this uh
this is related to the fact that the
gradient of the cube uh the description
behaves in a worse way and in fact this
is sort of miracle that you can save the
thing instead of we call it getting
inequality but in one direction and
actually you for hanan we
had some papers and other people had
papers exploiting this inequality so so
yeah
the proof is trigger and you you you
will find it in the slides right i i
don't want to get into technical detail
but this is like a few pages of
computation so this inequality can't be
reversed right with some other factor of
b
like on the left hand side uh the right
hand side can actually be arbitrarily
large compared to the left hand side
uh
yes for some functions
the right hand side may be much worse
than the left-hand side
on the discrete key
and i think even on the original and
back uh if if you get function that
takes the value zero it's not
certificate but it takes value zero
and the gradient behaves very strangely
in the proximity of zero you can also
get uh something that is not equally an
any longer right in the in the limiting
case but if you are bounded away from
zero and function is smooth then
the survivor plus will just change into
equality
for the other option
so this inequality in stroke variables
is actually reflecting
the difference between discrete gradient
and usual gradient and the fact that for
the discrete gradient you don't have as
nice chain formula when you
take derivative of the product or
compositional functions you don't get
as nice expression as
for standard gradient
and that result is hidden behind behind
them
but this is very useful inequality just
because it's so close to equality in so
many cases this is a very strong
inequality
okay so now
i would like just to describe two
results from the probabilities here so
one of them is kinship
inequality that most of you probably
heard about so assume that you have some
real numbers a 1 a 2 up to a n and you
add them up with random signs so you
look at the sums of the form plus minus
a 1 plus 1 minus a 2 plus minus a n
and then
once you have such a random sum
when sines are chosen independently of
probability one half
plus and minus
once you have such a sum you want to
compare its piece normal
with accused norm
b is greater than q greater than z and
actually
famous theorem of kinchen which he
proved when he was working on the law of
iterated logarithm but it was later used
in many other situations the claims
states that actually this is the case
that there is a constant depending only
on p and q but doesn't depend on the
actual choice of coefficients 1 up to a
n and doesn't depend on the number of
coefficients doesn't it
such that this bound
holds 2.
so this is quite unusual
of course always for p greater than q we
will have sp
greater equal than sq
but the quenching inequality tells you
that you can reverse the order of
inequality just paying the price of some
coefficient but depending on your own
png okay
and actually even something more is true
if you instead of taking real numbers
take vectors from some boundary space or
some linear noun space and you do the
same again the inequality holds true
with some constant which depends on your
pn this is the result of jean-pierre
kahan
uh
actually this is an open problem i i
promise to give some open problems so
this is probably a quite difficult open
problem it's not known whether these
optimal constants that appear in kingdom
inequality and kim jong-un are equal in
all cases where both constants are known
they are equal
so
cpq is equal to kpq
whenever cpq are known if one of those
is equal to two right this was proved by
hagero
but in general they are not known so for
example they are known if p and q are
both even numbers
even integers
but even that
is normally recently i think
and this is known only in few cases but
whenever both constants are known they
actually are equal and this is an old
question i think it was as a big
it was never published but but it's a
very natural question is the real case
somehow external and it seems like
hopeless
so it's known that as asymptotically
these things behave
in a very similar fashion so when p goes
to infinity the ratio between these two
things no matter what q is
oddly below p the ratio between this
strategy will go to one
this can be controlled but nothing more
original okay
does it depend on the spaces
no it doesn't it works for all
all normal spaces uniform
that's the point
this is the constant that doesn't depend
on the space doesn't depend on the
choice of vectors and on number of
vectors
it depends only on p and q situation
vectors
intuitively that's that's the extreme
case but proving is
well there are there are some situations
where you can prove that actually for
some particular barnard spaces you can
prove that the constant is the same in
real case and in vector space uh this is
for example whenever you you are in
euclidean space this is a quite nice
trick you just use
uh
sort of embedding you use gaussian
random variables to embed
uh gaussians into
euclidean space into real line and you
can prove that the kimchen constant and
kahan constant
in euclidean space are the same but if
you want to take over all
known spaces this is wide open
so is there like
a
gaussian
there is a gaussian equivalent of that
so you can replace rademachers plus
minus ones by gaussians and then it's
known that these two constants are
exactly equal
of course in real case for gaussians you
can compute you have equality instead of
inequality and you compute this is just
the ratio between piece and the choose
norm of the of the standard gaussian
random variable but actually the same
constant works in the
in the vector case and this is the
consequence of the so called s
inequality saying that among all convex
sets of fixed gaussian measure convex
symmetric the slowest growth of the
gaussian measure will be for this matrix
3
which translates more or less students
saying that the real line is external
so the gaussian
yeah thank you very much
i should have shown that in some big
chocolate
the gaussian case actually is known and
these constants are known to be equal in
gaussian case so that's another reason
to believe that in arabic it should be
similar but somehow the methods from the
gaussian case completely doesn't doesn't
seem to be transferable to the to the
other case so this fact that this ph and
qth moment can be compared even like uh
it holds for symmetric plus minus one
gaussian what other thing
oh for great random variables there is
the whole theory of hyper contractivity
of random variables so both in real case
and in this case you can characterize
the tail behavior of random variables so
that this sort of inequality is
satisfied
this is so-called hyper contractility of
the random variable and there is a paper
by fapping and shulga i think which
gives complete characterization in terms
of time
of course from behavior to getting exact
constant is not possible but
to know that this happens with some
universal concern depending on young
peer and two
this is known and this is completely
completely understood but this is not
trivial
and
actually the conditions are quite quite
awful especially the
independent space
but this is not
and well you can in banach space you can
ask not only about
real random variables but for example
for some
linear transformations as coefficients
and then i think it's wide open and
probably completely hopeless
but if you only ask about sums of
real random variable times vector
then this is understood
okay so this is just the statement uh
there is a long line of people who who
proves
the kinshin inequalities of optimal
constant and actually whittle gave one
of the first proof i think in the 60s
and then without knowing his results
along 20 years several people
independently gave similar proof so
somehow
it took some time to recognize little's
input in the theorem
and actually for the kahan inequality
there are two key cases when the
constants are known so it's known that
between second and first absolute moment
the constant is square root of two and
this is the same as in real case and
between fourth and second moment it's
fourth root of three and i will show you
the proof of both results for the kahan
inequality for the stronger
case and you will see that it follows
very easily from the properties of the
of the generator of the
distance
okay so just to tell you that why these
two constants are optimal so
even on real case this concern is
optimal just when you take two radar
matters with coefficients one then it's
very easy to see that you cannot beat
the square root
and
for
this constant you just take equal
coefficients and normalize and by
central limit theorem
in some appropriate form you see that
you cannot beat the ratio between
just what happens for gaussian and this
is the constant for gaussian okay so
it's very easy to see that you cannot do
better than this constant but now the
problem is how to prove the kahan
inequality with this with this constant
okay
so now
uh we take some vectors some n vectors
in some linear space
and
consider some semi norm if you if you
prefer it may be just a usual seminar is
the same as norm
just to allow the normals and vectors to
be equal to zero
you want homogeneity triangle inequality
but actually we can even weaken and not
insist on the fact that the norm of
vector equal to zero implies that the
detector is zero itself okay okay we can
skip that condition
so when we have a seminar on rn
we can
restrict it to the disc cube right we
can just treat the difficult cube
negative one one
uh
in power and as a subset
of rn
right so we restoring this seminar to
the discrete cube
and
we produce this seminar just by taking
the point x in rn
and multiplying x i by vi these are our
vectors and then taking norm from our
known space
okay
so i hope it's clear why
i say that this is a seminar not norm
because it may happen that these vectors
are linearly dependent and even if you
start with a norm on your banner space
on or your normal space
it may happen that for example v1 minus
v2 is equal to zero
right and then for the vector one one
you will have this seminar h equal to
zero okay so
really this degeneration to the seminar
may happen
okay so we define our seminar in this
way
for the point from r and
we consider this result and of course we
restrict to the descriptive because our
coefficients are plus minus ones
standing by the vertex right so so we
only need the same description and now
it has trivial properties first of all
this is non-negative point wise
before or after restriction doesn't
matter just because the norm is not
negative and also it's even just because
norm is a symmetric function
right so we have a non-negative given
function in the descriptor
now we will prove less obvious property
will prove that we have a pointwise
inequality
that l of h is not greater than h
this inequality is not true for every
function on the discrete
but we prove that this is true whenever
this function comes from some no
whenever it's a restriction of a seminar
or not
okay so i will actually give you two
proofs of that fact
first proof is by triangle inequality
we just recall that we can
write lf at point x
as such sum over all neighbors y of x
so we do that for hours and now so this
is just restriction of the seminar on on
rn so we can come back to this
and now
we can bound like that just because of
the triangle inequality
we have the sum of the
seminar of vectors
and we know that this is greater equal
than the
seminar of the sum of vectors this is
just a triangular inequality
it goes the inverse
the opposite direction just because we
have a minus here and here right
we sum over all y's which are neighbors
of x and we use the triangular
inequality to estimate this sum
from
below which gives us the estimate from
above of this expression because here we
have minus okay
but now when you sum over all neighbors
of x in the discrete cube
all immediate neighbors of x what you
get is n minus 2 times x
is it clear
just check it on the
vertex 1 1 1 1 1 1 1.
out of
the neighbors each neighbor differs on
exactly one coordinate
so when you add up
those neighbors
in n minus one summons the coordinate
will come with the same sign as in the
original vertex and in one case it will
come with the opposite sign
so after cancellation you will get n
minus 2 times x okay
so
what we arrive at is that things will
cancel out and we get just h of x which
is h
and we prove the inequality that we need
plus by triangle
nothing else
and this is just
what i said
about another sentence
okay and now another proof
which is not exactly the same as they
played before
we know that any seminar on rn can be
written as a supremum of linear
functionals this
in fact it's is easier because we are in
finite dimensional space
it's quite inventive okay so now for
each of these functionals when we
restrict it to the cn
we get just a linear combination of rada
major functions of degree one walsh
functions right
what is a linear function
it's a linear combination
of the things that we we have right so
after restricting
to
the distal cube again it will be a
linear combination which is nothing else
than the linear combination of
coordinate functions
which is exactly the rather like result
okay but we know
that radha mahals
namely walsh that are that are indexed
by sets of cardinality one by singletons
we know
that for them
the eigenvalue when we use operator l is
equal to one
let me remind you that the eigenvalue of
l is cardinality of s and eigen value of
the semi group is exponent minus t so
when we apply our semi group to function
phi
that is
linear
restricted to the discrete cube what we
get is immediately exponent minus t of y
this just acts as a multiplier with
constant exponent minus for any
non-negativity
but now we know that our seminar is
minor rated
minorized by each of this function are
separately pointwise and our semi group
it is under preserving so because of
that pt of h which is a restriction of
that is not less than pt of phi
which is exponent minus t of phi
and therefore we know that pt of h is
greater equal than this we have this for
any functional phi from our family
separate so it's greatly called than
supreme over all family but we know that
supreme over whole family is just our
seminar that we started
which after restriction to the
described by red light
okay
so now let's compute the generator l of
x by definition this is the minus right
hand side derivative at zero of the semi
load
so this is the
the fraction that we need to
to take limits off
but now we know that this expression is
not less than exponent minus th
so this
fraction is bounded from above by this
fraction but this unit would need to be
computed this is just same okay
so we have seen two probes one using
triangular inequality and the other
using positively preserving
a nice geometric structure of the semi
group over linear functions
i think both approaches are sort of
equivalent uh but i think it's good to
to see how both of them were because
especially the second approach is
usually in other situations
whenever geometric context come comes
okay anyway
now we will prove that the constant k 2
1 the kinchen kahn constant between
second and the first moment is square
root of and you will see that this is
just few line proof
we know these three properties h is our
our function that we want to estimate
our seminar generated
and the function because the function is
even we know that the poincare
inequality holds with constant one-half
remember we proved the pancreas
inequality of constant one-half under
additional assumption that function but
this is how it takes
also we know that lh is not greater than
h and h is on negative so point wise h l
h is bounded by h square these two
inequalities show that h times lh
is
less equal
than h squared so we have also
inequality between expectation
and that's the end
here we have second moment here we have
first
moment squared and here we'll have
second moment after we put things back
we end up
in the kinjunkahani quality of square
dot
okay
well you see that this is a few lines
and proof of the
handing the quality with constant square
root
and now
how to do the proof
uh for exponents four and two
can you see by the way
yes and i think recently the robustness
was studied by by some group of people
also some of them i think located in
berkeley
yeah but somehow i think it could be
also great from the original proof i
think not by the characters
i think now it was studied more
carefully and perhaps it will have some
importance to understand
what happens close to equality cases
uh
now
this inequality actually
the vector case here is much more
difficult than real case if you want to
prove the constant c for two for the
kinchen inequality for real coefficient
just this is just a few lines of proof
you see down you compute everything and
you end up with some
elementary network
there is nothing to prove but in the
vector case it's non-trivial
okay so now we use the same tree that we
used before but for h squared instead of
h but h squared is again an even
function
so again we use the poincare inequality
with constant one-half to the function h
squared instead of a
now we use the stroke variables in
equator to bound this expression
so using this stroke variables
inequality for p equal to 4 we can
replace h square l h square by h in
power 3 like
right this is non-negative function and
for the non-negative function we can use
the stroke variables
why do we do that well first because we
can do that right we cannot resist the
temptation second reason is that of
course we can bounce nicely from above
and h
i remember that we have this point
raised inequality for lh but we don't
know the same thing for lh square
so now we again bounce from above lh
point lines by age and h in power three
is not negative so the order of equality
is preserved
so putting things together putting this
bound and this bound together we end up
by binding
this difference first moment minus
second moment square
by some constant times first moment and
after you cancel the constants you end
up
so somehow you see that the distinct
variables inequality must be very close
to equality
in real
case uh just because you know how this
relates to the real tension inequality
right
and you see that in this gaussian limit
things must
must be very delicate
the way you use strong fireplace is very
close to equality in some cases
because you recover the optical constant
okay
so
i still have five minutes so maybe it's
a good time to stay the result and i i
will start tomorrow by hoping this with
us
uh so
what is the chaos
when you have some
uh variables x1 up to xn
you can consider a polynomial in these
variables with real coefficients and you
will say that this is of chaos style i'm
slightly abusing the the usual
definition so what i'm talking about is
usually called tetrahedral chaos
and chaos would be general
polynomial but
for my reason i will just
for my units here i will just call this
scales
to make it shorter so this will be a
polynomial search that
the terms
don't appear if in pi power higher than
2
so
for example x1
x2
x3 may appear in this polynomial
with nonzero coefficient but we don't
want terms like x1 x2 squared this is
for beta
okay we don't want powers higher than
one into appearing
we only want such a holy linear
appearance
okay and
now if we plug instead of this random
instead of this variable some
independently random variables then we
get some
random variable set that is a polynomial
in independent reality and moreover this
polynomial is of chaos style and such
thing is called
random chaos
and this is very important object for
example when you study
stochastic integration
uh
multi-dimensional stochastic integration
knowing how to control such terms of
speaking patterns in
theory
you you need to know how to bound
nicely this sort of
expansions
but now in our case what will be
important for us is that actually by
nature the world's fourier expansion is
an expansion of arbitrary function on
on the description into
the chaos
see right just because all
walsh functions are products of
coordinates
so we are lucky because in the
description every function
is just
a chaos random chaos with respect to the
underlying uniform measure
this is not the case on any other
actuary
products
space
only only on two point spaces we have
such a lucky situation
that's more or less the reason why
people need to bother with hermit
polynomials and so on right whenever you
move to
spaces higher than two point space you
don't have nice sequence of two
polynomials spanning everything identity
and
and constant polynomial right
this is the case for two point symmetric
space but nothing else and then you need
to
uh to have a large larger sequence of
polynomials for example hermits and
polynomials for gaussians and then you
need to tensorize them when you move to
higher dimension and things got
complicated but we are very lucky on the
description
everything is
completely so so so we are talking about
multiple in our polynomials right yes so
i don't want to question terminology but
like in computer science like you just
call it multi-linar so i don't see
like the chaos aspect of it or i mean
under chaos i mean chaos
is the name that comes
just from the stochastic integrations
here in probability this was considered
because of the stochastic integration
theory and this chaos
comes just from that theory and that was
useful
as a name for expansions especially the
galoshen chaos
the terms when you integrate with
respect to winner winner process
especially
against many linear processes the terms
that come out uh ito calculus and so on
and this is called chaos
that that has nothing to do with the
theory in terms of deterministic chaos
for example
this is just an idea that that this
polynomial map is somehow chaotic
no it has nothing to do with the dynamic
property of the it's on the right the
name chaos
this is the older chaos from which the
dynamical coils emerged and later the
sky entirely
yes
yeah but this is just to tell you the
terminology because in many
probabilistic papers you may
come up on this notion and just to let
you know what it means for probabilities
okay so now
tomorrow i i would like to start from a
very simple lemma
this is some elementary moment
comparison will prove that for any
chaos
uh
we can bound the fourth moment
by second moment squared times
nine in power d where d is the degree of
the polynomial so whenever you have a
boolean function you have a function on
the descriptive real value function and
you know
that the welsh fourier coefficients
disappear
for all s with currently greater than d
then you know that this sort of estimate
holds with constant nine in poverty
uh this appears in reynolds notes
uh under the name of bonami lemma and in
fact probably alina bonami was one of
the first people
to consider this sort of estimate i
don't know whether in exactly this form
but definitely the same sort of
inequalities were considered by alina
bonami she was doing harmonic analysis
and perhaps even rudin
before realized this sort of estimates
sorry
was the first but
this is usually associated with the name
of bonami but because
i try to read through these papers and
it's quite difficult to see
uh where the breakthrough happens i i
guess probably banami was
was first to realize this phenomenon in
this generation
okay so the constant nine in power d
here is not optimal
uh
for example when d is equal to one you
can prove the inequality with constant
three not nine
but this is the optimal asymptotics in
the sense that when
the
d goes to infinity you can prove
that this root of this ratio
in some particular case for some
particular function can be bounded from
below by nine
so even for small d you can prove it
with slightly better constant
asymptotic growth like nine to power d
is optimal and in the slice i will not
show you the pro will not have time for
that but in the slides there is a
particular example
of a function which is actually very
simple you
just take all
walshes
with degree d and you sum them and you
can compute things directly and rest way
so there are simple examples showing
that the speed of growth is actually
optimal okay so tomorrow we'll start
with the proof of this lemma which will
be just one screen as you can see and
very simple
and then we'll pass to something more
complicated that is called
entropic inequalities and
and hyper contractivity and
well i hope we will end up with probing
hyperventilativity and seeing some
applications to study it i hope i will
manage to do that i will try to speak
faster
okay so thank you